[Musique]
ce qu'il vit du tulle et celui qui
m'importe le plus de joie dans la vie
trois ou six amis je me souviens de
notre première rencontre s'est dégradée
du sable
[Musique]
j'ai quelque chose pour toi
selon les vrais jamais
[Musique]
non
bon les amis quelle est la suite des
événements pour mystère et compagnie
[Musique]
holla holla holla sammy et scooby ont
été enlevées dans leur famille
normalement tu dois te passer de m c'est
fini chez vous ça va se pointer
si l'on me dérange pas vous pouvez vous
garer au bras descendre ici fratrie
apparemment il a grugé netflix en
utilisant le compte de sa mère c'est
tellement injuste pour tous ceux qui
doivent payer pour regarder mes tricks
quoi faut payer pour regarder les 6